if Israel's new government has its way
this building could house a far less
powerful Supreme Court potential changes
announced by the Justice Minister would
enable Parliament to overrule the
Court's decisions reversing a
decades-old system of checks and
balances
as Benjamin Netanyahu returns to power
as prime minister he faces three court
cases involving charges of bribery fraud
and breach of trust changes to the legal
system were a major demand of right-wing
politicians who backed Netanyahu and
that sparked anger and protests we
except fully the elections that took
place a few weeks ago
but then what happens with the new
government is that they really create
a major and significant danger to
Israel's existence and democracy with
the extremists with the extremists that
are there in the government we see with
all the intentions of putting forward
legislation that will ruin the the
judicial system
the potential changes are unpopular in
Tel Aviv the city has long been seen as
a center of liberal thought in Israel
and now thousands of people have began
to protest weekly so I came here to
protest against the degradation of the
Israeli democracy we see a process where
the rights of the people will be over
time consumed by this Theocratic
government and we want to avoid that but
it's not just about internal Israeli
Politics the Supreme Court has also
ruled on the legality of settlements in
the occupied West Bank which are illegal
under international law but with this
government being backed by extreme
right-wing parties it's unlikely the
demonstrations will have the impact the
protesters hope
for now it's being discussed in a
parliamentary committee if and when it
gets the knesset Parliamentary floor for
a vote at its past it will be a
significant erosion of a system of
checks and balances on this right-wing
government Imran Khan Al Jazeera West
Jerusalem